here are some facts about great white
sharks white sharks are live birth
usually in litters of between four and
seven individuals now they're called
pups but when they're born they're
between 1.2 and 1.5 meters so that's a
pretty big baby
it takes a great white shark about 10 to
12 years to reach maturity at which
point the females are actually about a
metre longer than the males the largest
recorded being over 6 meters roughly the
size of this rent boat binds at this
length they'd weigh about 2 to 3,000
kilograms oh man now there are stories
of some great whites being over 7 meters
but those are unsubstantiated white
sharks are warm bodies they're not
warm-blooded like us they can't maintain
a perfectly stable temperature but their
internal organs are kept at up to 13
degrees above the average temperature of
the ambient water around them the heat
generated by their muscles is actually
transferred to the blood in their veins
as it returns from the Sharks
extremities so it warms it up and keeps
the core temperature a little bit hotter
this allows the shark to venture into
colder waters and also to have explosive
power its muscles work a lot better when
warm than when cold just like ours the
trade-off is the shark requires about 10
times as much energy as if it didn't
heat its body and that's why they need
to feed on these blubber rich seals and
whale carcasses white sharks like to
hunt when it's light out because they
use their eyesight to spot their prey
but when they open their jaws their eyes
actually roll back into their head to
protect them and so they're actually
blind when they're taking a bite now
they do like conditions that are a
little bit low visibility because they
rely on stealth to track down their prey
if a seal spots them coming it's
basically game over because the seal is
so much more maneuverable and can
definitely get away from the shark but
they only eat sea mammals after they're
about 2.5 meters long which is why most
of the Sharks we're seeing around here
are quite large before that they're died
consists mainly of fish the gestation
period is thought to be about 18 months
and that leads to a two to three year
reproduction cycle and with such small
litters that means it takes a long time
for this shark population to recover
there are a couple of misconceptions
about great white sharks one is that
they can't get cancer and that's led to
a lot of people hunting them down and
trying to use their fins as an
anti-cancer soup but in reality sharks
get cancer just like anything else and
there's photographic evidence of sharks
with big tumors so it makes no sense to
hunt down sharks as a cancer remedy
because they get cancer just like we do
another misconception is sharks are
coastal creatures that just cruise the
beaches waiting to bite people in
reality the Sharks spend much of their
time way away out at sea and very deep
over a kilometer deep it's kind of
shocking but we've only found this out
in the last couple of years so there's
so much about sharks that remains
undiscovered we don't know where they go
or what they do for most of the time
that they're alive and that's why
research projects like this are so
important to find out more about the
shark and figure out how we can help it
rehabilitate and and become the predator
of the sea that it once was
you